[Music]
welcome back to science clique today
supercritical fluids
mata can exist in different states
in our daily lives on earth there are
three states of matter
solid liquid and gas
each of these three forms corresponds to
a microscopic configuration
in a solid molecules are fixed in
relation to each other they have a
regular structure because they are
strongly bound
in a liquid molecules are more loosely
bound they are free to move around but
they maintain a certain cohesion
a liquid can be deformed but it
conserves a certain volume
this contrasts with gases in which
molecules are free to move around and
eventually take up the entire volume in
which they are contained
depending on the temperature and
pressure of the environment a body will
naturally be in one of these three
states
for instance at atmospheric pressure and
in the range between 0 and 100 degrees
celsius water is naturally liquid
these are the conditions of our
atmosphere and explains why liquid water
can be found on the planet
if the temperature were 200 degrees
celsius keeping pressure constant water
would be found as a gas
water vapor
in order to model the conditions
required for the presence of each of the
three states of mata we can draw a phase
diagram
such a diagram represents the phase of
water in other words the state in which
it occurs naturally for different values
of pressure and temperature
[Music]
we start by taking a tightly sealed
container into which we will pour water
the temperature inside the container can
be adjusted through heating or cooling
and the pressure can be altered by
pressing or pulling a piston
to fill in the diagram we will use three
colors we choose to use grey for gas
light blue for liquid
and dark blue for solid
each point of the diagram corresponds to
a unique temperature pressure
combination which we will replicate
inside the container
once the settings have been chosen we
can observe which phase the water inside
the container is in
and draw a small square on the diagram
with the corresponding color
by repeating this process for multiple
values we finally obtain a map on which
three zones appear
if a given pressure temperature pair
lands inside one of these zones for
example in the dark blue zone this means
that under these specific conditions
water is naturally in a solid state
one of the first things that stands out
is the fact that the three zones have
precise boundaries
when we are at the limit between two
zones the two states on either side of
the boundary can co-exist simultaneously
in a stable way
for instance when we heat up an ice cube
under atmospheric pressure it gradually
moves to the right of the diagram as its
temperature increases
when we reach the limit of the solid
zone a temperature of zero degrees
celsius the very first drops of liquid
water appear
gradually the ice cube melts while
remaining at the same temperature
the energy supplied through heating no
longer changes its temperature but
instead causes it to melt to rearrange
its molecules on a microscopic scale
once the ice cube is entirely melted its
temperature will start to rise again
signaling a movement into the zone of
the diagram corresponding to the liquid
state
we have performed a phase transition
going from one state of mata to another
by crossing one of these boundary curves
another point which deserves mentioning
is that there exists a point at which
the three zones touch
this is a point of contact between each
possible state of matter
solid liquid and gas
under these specific conditions of
temperature and pressure it is thus
possible for water to coexist in a solid
liquid and gas form all at once
this peculiar setting is called the
triple point
for water this triple point corresponds
to a pressure of 0.6 percent of an
atmosphere and a temperature of 100 of a
degree celsius
conditions that do not occur naturally
on earth but which we can create in a
lab allowing us to surprisingly boil
water while some of it is simultaneously
frozen
[Music]
coming back to the phase diagram what
interests us most is the fact that the
curve separating liquid and gas seems to
stop abruptly
this specific point where the curve
stops is the critical point
it corresponds to a very high
temperature and pressure combination
conditions that do not occur naturally
on earth but which can be reproduced in
a laboratory
let's take our water container and
adjust its pressure and temperature in
order to lie on this curve
as we have seen at the boundary between
the two zones water appears
simultaneously in two different states
liquid and gas
inside the container we see a separation
between liquid water and water vapor
let's now gradually heat and compress
the container so that we approach the
critical point while remaining on the
curve
as pressure increases the water
molecules in the gas are strongly
compressed
they come closer together and take up
less space
the vapor becomes more dense
on the other hand increasing the
temperature forces the molecules in the
liquid to vibrate more and more
in this way the molecules are less bound
to each other and their increasing
agitation makes them occupy more space
the liquid water becomes less dense
gradually the separation between the
liquid and the vapor becomes less and
less visible
suddenly the density of the liquid which
decreases and that of the gas which
increases reach the same value
from that moment on the two phases are
no longer distinct the liquid and the
gas in the container have exactly the
same density
we obtain a sort of homogeneous mixture
of liquid and gas we've reached the
critical point
beyond this point it is impossible to
distinguish the gas from the liquid
the two phases have merged into one
the state of this water is neither
liquid nor gas
its behavior is fairly similar to that
of a gas but it also exhibits
interesting properties that are usually
attributed to liquids
we call this state a supercritical fluid
it is interesting to note that unlike
the solid state liquid and gas are not
independent
although it is possible to go from
liquid to gas by transition by boiling
water
it is also possible to go from liquid to
gas without any such transition
to do this we simply adjust the
temperature and pressure in our
container in order to bypass the
boundary between the two states
we start with a liquid and by making it
a supercritical fluid we can transform
it into a gas
this experiment is astonishing to
observe
it is very unusual to witness a liquid
becoming a gas without any visible
transition
taking our supercritical fluid once
again we can observe a surprising
phenomenon as we approach the critical
point
as the fluid reaches this point it
spontaneously begins to scatter light
this is called critical opalescence
it is due to the refraction of light
within the fluid
light rays slow down depending on the
fluid's density
as it approaches the critical point the
fluid has to split into a liquid and a
gas
but just before this happens it
hesitates between one state and the
other
these hesitations within the fluid lead
to strong density fluctuations which
scatter light
in the same way that our atmosphere
scatters sunlight giving the sky its
colour
in our daily lives supercritical fluids
have many
applications their properties are very
interesting
for instance although they behave mainly
like a gas we can use them as solvents
they can serve to extract certain
substances
supercritical carbon dioxide
is widely used to extract flavors from
plants nicotine from tobacco or even
caffeine from coffee
a major advantage of supercritical co2
is that unlike liquid solvents it is
non-toxic and relatively easy to use
with a very high extraction power
in its supercritical form water is also
a very good solvent it is useful for
destroying organic waste without
releasing harmful gases as opposed to
burning it
supercritical fluids have a multitude of
diverse practical applications
such as fuel production
refrigeration
or even microbial protection
to conclude the supercritical fluid is a
state of matter in its own right
above a certain pressure and temperature
point
liquid and gas seem to merge
forming a single homogeneous state
with both gas and liquid-like properties
on earth temperature and pressure are
too low to allow for such fluids to
exist in a natural form
only small quantities can be found at
the bottom of the ocean within
hydrothermal vents
where temperature and pressure are
extreme
although rare on earth supercritical
fluids are relatively common in the
universe
especially inside gaseous planets
within their atmospheres the conditions
are so extreme that some layers are
actually supercritical
similarly the very hot and thick
atmosphere of venus can reach 500
degrees celsius and a pressure a hundred
times greater than on earth
under such conditions the atmosphere of
the planet consisting mainly of carbon
dioxide is a supercritical fluid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you